it's about building something changing
the world like it's not like changing
the world but changing the world the way
a specific old fashioned industry works
today it's working with my team like
every day there are new challenges every
day
there are new success or failures and
but it's like i keep saying that i
never felt alive the way i feel in the
last year and a half wow
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
20-minute leaders is a proud supporter
of make-a-wish israel and tech to peace
and is in proud collaboration with
secret core adventures j ventures
riverside fm
fusion vc
birthright excel j impact leap google
for startups and hippo and in media
partnership with c-tech
hello and welcome to 20 minute leaders
today we are with inval galanza of homes
looking at home renovations and
construction and the relationship
between the new generation that is
wanting the renovation and construction
with the contractors and how do we
bridge that gap with intersection
in bali is a graduate of the programming
course in mamram and 8200 alumni as an
officer she had 20 years in tech
executive positions in local and global
companies before deciding to be an
entrepreneur imbala is a mother of three
teenage boys and homies is a unicorn
from the beginning it is so rare to find
a construction tech company founded by
women only
[Music]
in bal glancer welcome to 20 minute
leaders thank you so much for joining me
how are you good thank you for inviting
me i we're in the beautiful google for
startups uh is our office as well this
is your office with homemade looking at
home renovations and a fascinating
background that you have and i'm curious
how you got into home renovations in the
first place from the open university in
oracle and different endeavors what was
it about home renovations that really
sort of took your interest well actually
i'm kind of a renovation junkie like my
professional is being a data engineer i
started my career in my mom and
8200 unit
and then i can take executive position
in all kinds of companies but all along
the way i renovate i i made many
renovation projects like our
own house i renovated at least four
times
and uh we bought like an apartment for
it and maybe they flip you know and this
is something that i've done
all my life i mean there's a lot of
aspects to renovations right there's the
the actual logistical aspect of it of
creating a project management end to end
which is so complicated so many moving
pieces but then you have the creative
pieces so which one of these are you
more interested in it's both like i took
the the apartment that the
the investment uh one that we made i
took a two and a half bedroom apartment
and
converted it to four all by myself
without an architect or interior
designer and this is like the creative
part how like to redesign it and the
project management part was like to find
the right professional to do the work
and
be on budget and this is like the huge
uh challenge and this is where ole miss
is about not about the creative part but
about
the budget the project management like
how you start and how you end your
project why is it so complicated
because there are many uh moving parts
in this kind of projects and there are
many surprises like
usually you don't know what is going on
behind the tires for example and then
once
you remove the tire you said okay we
have to replace the plumbing
at all and so i'm categorizing that as
unexpected events along the way this
ability of unpred this element of
unpredictableness and ability to pivot
and to change as you're going through
the project exactly and it's also about
the professionals that are managing
these uh projects
most of them like they have their own
knowledge and even though
even if it's like they have 20 years of
experience
which is like a lot of time to be a
professional in this field
this like industries keep changing and
they like if they are not on pace and
they don't learn and
really learn their business and most of
them don't
um
they don't know how to estimate
correctly and to
i predict what's going on in this
project uh so
this is like another way that
brings you to the project many surprises
and you end with like a significant
division on budget and time sure take me
back to the inflection point of where
homemade starts right so you're already
well into your career and
you're thinking about all the different
things that you can do and you choose to
start homemade so obviously you're
excited about renovations and you've
taken a lot of these projects yourself
but but there's a gap between
doing these independent projects and
starting a whole company and dedicating
yourself to a 10-year journey on this
world yeah what was it really that made
that said you know what i'm doing this
well my co-founder nama she is an
architect and we are
very good friends like for
many years
and she came with that idea and it was
at the beginning of kovid like about
april's april 2020
i think yeah so it she came with the
idea and it was like
i want to do that it's like
i i have to do that
it it really surprised me because until
that moment i was in a in in a progress
of becoming like next an executive
manager right and then you in huge
companies and uh
i i wasn't ready for this kind of change
so i wanted to do that but at the
beginning i was like okay i really want
to do that
but
i'm not going to do that i it's not
responsible there is coffee and i have
kids um i don't know
like not i'm not going to have salary
for four years
um
so
she started with another co-founder
and then i felt like
a huge um
miss
interesting
and i thought come on why why didn't you
take this challenge so you did so when
you first said no it wasn't from a lack
of interest or a lack of excitement it
was more of you know life's getting in
the way we have all these reasons of
stability and covet and you know
i have to reiterate on this feeling of
what made you then go back and say no i
actually want to do this well
after uh about a month
co-founder um there was something
personal in his life and he decided that
he can't take this like a journey
and she was back to the
beginning and that was the moment that i
told her i'm in i want to do that
because i felt
i i felt like how i miss something big
an opportunity to do something else
and i'm not like um i mean i was at the
beginning of my 40s
and like this is my time to to do that
and they want to do it with you and uh
that was the moment that we decided that
we are going on that and was she already
on on the route with homemade already
with sort of the idea and
yeah well it was it's already changed we
we've
appeared at the beginning it was it was
a marketplace for homeowners to find
their uh
to find the contractors for their
projects like it was from our personal
pain
um but when we started working with
contractors we found out that they are
way way behind the
in technology uh point of view so we
understood that first of all we are
going to provide them a very good
solution that fits their lifestyle and
the way they think
maybe in the future we will get to the
marketplace i love it so let's do a deep
dive into the way that contractors today
do these home renovations and the way
that they get their estimates the way
that they plan
you're you need to prioritize obviously
which features you're building out and
what are the most important issues so
what what was your understanding after
this pivot as to what are the most
critical issues in the pipeline or the
life cycle of these projects well it is
based on really main
two uh
uniqueness points that we provide them
the one
the first one and the most important one
that we are based on data
like
you are not alone anymore it's really a
lonely business being a contractor it's
like because they don't share
information yeah they don't share they
don't have where to take this
information they don't know what are a
market benchmarks how is their
competition it it takes them a lot of
time to build an estimate to like to
or the all the parts and make sure they
didn't forget anything sure and they are
also like
uh
other factors that impact a
pricing or timeline of a project that
are not related to the renovation at all
like what kind of elevator in this
building is it is service or passengers
elevator
this is something that changed the way
they they work there the way they can
like use this elevator
um
so we took we are taking all the data
from the market external sources and of
course uh internal and propriety data
and provide them like real-time insights
about what's going on
uh
on market in this building in this area
what is the suggested price to do this
specific work
and it's uh and like we guide them
through the process okay you're going to
renovate one bathroom one kitchen this
is what you should make sure you will
not forget
is there a heavy plaster roll
uh two layers of flooring all this kind
of uh of the
data and and with
the market benchmark so this is one
point the other one is about the process
currently it's a broken process like you
meet a customer you're in a site meeting
you write your notes and then
you
you go back to your office you need to
find this time to build the estimate
you're working on your notes you find
out that you forgot to ask something you
didn't notice something now you're
looking for the homeowner to ask the
question
it takes a lot of time
the way we build our solution it's like
you are in this meeting you write down
directly in in the app like this is what
should be done tick tick tick
and once you finish the meeting you
already have a proposal ready to start
to share with the customer or at least
as a draft everything is inside
and
and you can work on it so i'm hearing
that i'm seeing two different main
benefits here one is sort of this
benchmarking idea of how do we get the
best practices from the market and we we
don't turn it we take a lonely business
and a solo job and we turn it into now
sort of a sharing idea of
not they don't necessarily have to
communicate with other contractors but
they can communicate with event with an
entity that represents the benchmark for
the contractors yeah on the other hand
you're saying well there's this whole
organizational piece of it where today
it's very archaic they're taking notes
on these different notebooks and
different platforms let's consolidate it
in a way that allows them to sort almost
automate a process for a proposal which
makes them more effective and everything
else that they need to do and it
probably also makes it a little bit more
attractive to the person who's receiving
the proposal yeah definitely they look
more professional modern like um
most of uh most of the budget on home
improvements and renovations in the last
year in the us was spent by millennials
millennials are young people that expect
their suppliers
they work with for a better
experience a better digital experience
it's not like they are not accepting
anymore this like all the way
traditional way
right and so
how how much of that is is being put
into sort of the productization of this
is there right now an interaction
or planning for interaction between
you know generation z them or the
millennials that are doing that are
asking for these renovations and how how
are they integrated into this process
because until now we spoke about the
contractors and the benefits for them
but how are the
sort of the customers fitting into this
well once they once the proposal is
ready they share it with the customer
through the system so they get a
digitized
proposal where they can
comment on it ask questions
ask for
changes
and it's like a
ping pong with the contractor and
everything is written like if you decide
to make changes even when the project is
started
it's all in the system you see when you
ask that what was the answer once a
change order is done it's all documented
and um
in in a digital way like you're not
looking on your emails whatsapps all
that
right what did you learn about
either contractors or the or the ones
that are the customers through this
experience so far some non-trivial
things that
that have come up as you know whether it
be their workflow or or the way that
they are thinking about these projects
or their communication habits well they
have like
about specific specifically about
contractors they really have bad
reputations
better reputation about they how they
want like to get more money during a
project and this is how they make their
margin like first win
and
like so trust is an issue yes so trust
and reputation is really an issue for
them and they suffer from this
because um
from the first meeting they are like
started with
a
a customer that think they are going to
lie
or to to
they want like him not to be um
happy with the result is this a global
phenomenon specifically in israel no no
we are not in israel at all yeah well no
no it's a joke of course yeah well our
solution is for the us we are not in
israel at all so it's the same like the
same in israel interesting it's the same
in the us so they really want
they are looking for solutions
that will help them build the trust with
their customers uh to be more productive
to be uh
more efficient to know how like they are
really know how to build but they know
they know they don't know how to run a
business efficient way so
we they are looking for solutions for
these parts
and um
i find many contractors that keep
thinking about how i'm going to be
better tomorrow than i am today
and it was quite surprising
interesting tell me about you know
building trust i love human computer
interaction and the way that we can
leverage technology and digitalization
to create trust between parties
especially because here you have a
mediator that can filter through what's
real and what's not real how are you
thinking about this trust mechanism in
the context of customers and contractors
because
it sounds like this is a pretty
essential piece for the value
proposition that you're providing here
well
i think that
well it it comes from many different
paths to build this pa this trust like
it's not one thing of course so it's
about the the how detailed you provide
your proposal to
um to the customer the way like it was
calculated and how transparent you are
with like what you are going to do and
what is the period and what you think
you are you don't know yet and these
parts may be um
around the project but
for example
if it will happen this is how it's going
to cost like i'm not going to surprise
you sure because
during the project once
you are connected with me and you have
nothing to do with them
i'm
up front going to tell you if this will
happen this will cost you 500
let's see if if it not it's not but
we are on the same page you know what's
going to
what will be there do you find that the
benchmarking is helpful for customers or
are you even working on on is
benchmarking an interesting
place to create transparency with
customers do you think
i'm sure it is but we are not currently
we are not providing the benchmarking to
the
homeowner's final customer
currency the benchmarking is to help the
contractors
to make their pricing much more
um
competitive identity is irrelevant don't
lose and don't be overpricing sure
uh so in the future
like the way we build our solution it
like we want to be the standard sure in
a way that the customer the homeowner
will ask for a pricing
his project with omaze because they will
know this is like with a
market benchmark and it's reliable and
it was very detailed
and
so this is like
this is where our vision is going hello
then well this was so wonderful but i'm
left with the most important question
why are you so excited about homies why
do you wake up with energy
you know you is running a startup is
difficult as it is yeah and where where
is sort of this passion coming from wow
it's like and you know it's it's really
difficult and it's like a
huge effort i work i don't know about 18
uh hours a day that's it
and
i travel a lot to the us because this is
where our business
is and they have three children it's
like it's not easy uh but it is
about it's about building something
changing the world like it's not like
changing the world but changing the
world away
specific old
fashioned industry works today
everything is manual and really helped
these professionals to be better and in
this way help the homeowners
um
it's working with my team like every day
there are new challenges every day
there are new success or failures and
but it's like i keep saying that i
never felt alive the way
i feel in the last year and a half wow
that's a big statement yeah it's a big
statement like i'm full with the um
motivation to do that they wake up and
that's it once i open the computer i i
don't remember anything else i should do
like incredible
incredible i think that that's it that's
pretty much the feeling that probably
every person wants to get to in their
life and so it's a i think that's a
that's an incredible answer and best of
luck with homies it sounds wonderful
thank you for spending your time here
with me and best of luck with with
digitizing a really old-fashioned
industry the conversation about trust i
think is particularly interesting
especially for me with on a human
computer interaction basis and
really what you're doing here also
you're mentioning we're bridging gap
between generations we have the
contractors on one side let's put them
on the older generation side and then we
have the new millennials in generation z
which i didn't realize they are the
proponents of today's
real home improvement
industry and so how do we leverage
technology to to bridge that gap i think
that's really really fascinating and
thank you very much for being here thank
you very much for inviting me it was fun
thank you my first podcast
it was amazing thank you
[Music]